[Music]
a new children's book series first
conversations is designed to help
families talk about difficult topics
like race and gender the authors megan
madison and jessica reilly say they
wanted to write books they never had
growing up here's a reading from their
book our skin the first conversation
about race
our skin is beautiful strong and
important just the way it is
what do you love about your skin
just by looking at someone we can't tell
who they are on the inside
but sometimes people try to anyway
racism happens in lots of big and small
ways
racism can be an idea like thinking
princesses only have blonde hair
racism can be on purpose
like calling a person of color a mean
name
racism hurts
and is always unfair
that's why it's important to talk about
it
and to do our part to make things better
[Music]
people are working for racial justice
by telling the truth and sharing
feelings
by treating people the way they want to
be treated
megan madison and jessica riley thank
you so much for joining us this morning
now race and gender can be difficult for
adults
how do we break it down for kids
i think that's a really important
question and one that megan and i
thought about a lot you know as early
childhood educators
something that you have to do all the
time is take really big ideas
and break them down for very small kids
so we thought a lot about words and
concepts and sometimes our sentences
started as like 15 words and we broke
them down into maybe four or five words
and we practiced a lot on kids
we had many conversations with my own
children to kind of see what's stuck and
what they understood how old are your
kids my kids are now five and eight but
when we started writing the book they
were four and six
i wonder too megan at what age should
you start having this conversation with
kids because i remember my kids are now
34 and 35 so they're employed in potty
trained so
we're past a race conversation but when
i first started having it there were
four or five they had will in particular
they had no concept of color
like they were guessing like he said you
know you're white daddy's black they
honestly did not see color yeah yeah
every child is different
but studies show that most young
children are starting to notice
differences in skin color and also
notice big unfair patterns in the world
like why are there only boys on our
money or why in our school do the people
with white skin like why are they in
charge and all the people who cook our
food or
clean up our trash why do they have
browsing yeah kids are noticing those
patterns and developing questions
whether they have the language to
express them or not maybe they don't
know what it means exactly at what age
do you think you should start having
this conversation i mean i think it's
never too early to start so i often tell
parents right now is the right time um
but i think as soon as your children are
noticing things it's worth opening the
conversation and exploring what
questions do they have so kids are
noticing but i remember from my
childhood and i think a lot of people at
home will remember being taught color
blindness as the ideal oh you're
noticing all these things but don't
notice actually just treat everyone the
same and this book takes a very
different approach when did things shift
and why that's a great question yeah i
think that colorblind ideology that i
was also raised with does two things
first of all
it denies the lived reality of lots of
people of color in our country who are
impacted by systemic racism and who may
be treated differently because of their
skin color and then the other thing it
does is it completely shuts down the
conversation so if you can't see
something then you obviously can't talk
about it and you just can't fix anything
that you can't acknowledge and you can't
understand yeah we were all raised that
way
be colorblind and i now don't think that
that's such a good idea somebody told me
the phrase color brave and i like that
so much better than color blindness that
actually go there because talking about
race talking about now gender is very
uncomfortable for people
and i would add that you know if you
don't have these kind kinds of
conversations if you're wondering like
oh is my child seeing color i'm not sure
i'm not sure i should start the
conversation what happens is that
children do come to their own
conclusions for sure they will they will
figure it out on their own and those
conclusions often will include bias and
gender stereotypes because those are the
dominant messages in society or
influenced by somebody else that
shouldn't be leading them in these
conversations now speaking of those
conversations should it change depending
on child's race
i mean i think i'm an early childhood
educator and we use this concept of
developmentally appropriate practice
which is a very long fancy word but
essentially it means with every
conversation you want to take into
consideration both what you know about
that specific child each child is
different also what you know about in
general child development and then the
third piece is context it's going to be
a different conversation for a
two-year-old multi-racial kid growing up
in sacramento versus a six-year-old
indigenous kid growing up in oklahoma
so you're going to think about every
parent every educator is going to think
about all those different factors
because there's no one right
conversation they're all going to be a
little different no doubt about it thank
you so much for joining us megan and
madison
megan madison and jessica riley first
conversation series available wherever
you buy your books we'll be right back
after this this is awesome stuff thank
you